well the brethren about the Supreme
Court why is the Supreme Court such a
secret institution well the court in its
200 years of existence has managed to
keep itself out of the limelight not
totally out of the limelight it's been
controversial as it's going on but
unlike the presidency and the
legislative branches which both have
elective officials who are constantly
out there campaigning constantly under
scrutiny constantly being examined by
the public the court has essentially
drawn the wagons up his seal itself off
in a chamber has essentially said we
will speak in only one manner we will
speak through our written opinions and
we will not Brook any other kind of
scrutiny or interference and as a result
they've had this option as long as
they've maintained their silence of
being free from any type of real
in-depth look at what the institution
looks like as a result it's kind of
textbook myth of how the of how the
court operates the kind of civics sense
that the court is a series of nine
philosophers who read the Constitution
come out with pure ideals and and sit
down has endured even though everyone
has one or another of the things that
courts have done in the last two dozen
years that they find objectionable I
mean the court has in fact been very
controversial in doing your research for
the book the brother did you find that
most people within the legal profession
agree that specifically the Supreme
Court needs to be a secret as it is well
we we did in fact find a large number of
people after we had had gotten behind
the scenes who suddenly thought that
that was a mistake that it was that the
court should not be examined but by and
large I think the court itself and those
people that have been scholars of the
court those people who really no other
court functions
felt that the court was better off for
having some of its human foibles exposed
for being itself considered to be a
human institution one of the things that
we found I think the most important
group of court observers are the
justices themselves and in talking with
them both during the course of doing the
book and after the book came out what we
found was that while none of them want
to be quoted none of them want to have
this attributed to them they felt that
the country needs to understand their
problems which are sense the country's
problems that if the country can't
resolve certain things
if legislators can't resolve capital
punishment issues if prosecutors can't
figure out when to to prosecute and when
to let somebody go if they've abused
somebody's personal rights if
legislators and local communities and
doctors can't deal with abortion issues
things like that these things end up at
the Supreme Court the Supreme Court is
not a group of nine philosophers and
therefore I think the court felt that
people needed to know what it's like to
look at these issues ultimate societal
issues one after another good morning we
are live from our studios here in
Washington DC and this hour we're gonna
be talking about the Supreme Court
joining us to do this is the co-author
of this book this is an old battered
copy I apologize for but it's a fairly
old books book so we thought it'd be
more appropriate if it's if it's used
and yes we did by its the Brethren
inside the Supreme Court Bob Woodward
co-author of all the president's men and
Scott Armstrong and Scott's joining us
now live in our studios he currently is
the executive director of the National
Security Archive which is a nonprofit
corporation identifies and obtains
analyzes and houses government documents
pertaining to foreign Defense
Intelligence and national security
policy he is on leave from the
Washington Post preparing a book doing
1986 on national security
decision-making
we'll talk a little bit about that later
on prior to working at the post he
assisted Bob Woodward and Carl Bernstein
and research and writing of the final
days and was a senior investigator on
the Senate Select Committee on
presidential campaign practices the
Watergate committee from 73 to 74 he has
a BA degree in philosophy from Yale
University attended Harvard Law School
for one year has is married and has five
children this is something a little bit
different from what we normally do on
this program generally we hold up the
front page of the newspaper or editorial
page or op-ed page and talk about what's
in the news today this week here on
c-span we are taking about 1520 hours of
our programming and devoted devoting it
to a look at the courts in America and
taking a look specifically at the
federal courts and the Supreme Court and
each evening beginning at about 7:00
p.m. this week from 7:00 till about
10:30 we will be introducing you to some
of the people who are involved in the
judicial system and those who are
commenting on it or criticizing the way
the courts do their work so each evening
this week will be do
and for the next hour a little bit
different not the headlines in the
morning newspapers but instead a very
close look at the Supreme Court and
specifically this book the Brethren tell
us something about the book it was it
was a best-seller at one point a lot of
people heard about it read about it it
pertains primarily to the Supreme Court
from 1968 to 1976 is that correct that's
right what were you trying to accomplish
with this book well Carl what we what we
set out to do was was relatively naive
we we recognized we started in 1977 in
1978 to work on this we we recognized
that the other major institutions of
government during the 1970s Congress and
the and the executive branch had come
under enormous scrutiny you remember
there was Watergate there were a series
of congressional scandals Congress
itself course was involved the
resolution of Watergate and during this
entire period the court also was
involved in these same issues issues
like busing issues like the death
penalty issues issues including
Watergate and yet the one group that no
one knew anything about was the Supreme
Court all we knew was really what their
opinions were there were some rumors of
controversy internally but nobody had
really gone back and taking a look at
what this really meant so what we
decided to do was simply start at Ground
Zero let's forget everything we've heard
about the Supreme Court let's go to the
people that know that most about it
let's go to the justices of the Supreme
Court and ask them for their cooperation
and talk to them on whatever terms
they're willing to talk to us about
cases that are already complete and was
we didn't try and interfere with what
they were doing then we didn't ask them
about cases they were sitting on at that
moment we asked them about the previous
seven years of their the courts life so
as most this book put together from
information that you obtained interviews
with the Supreme Court justices I would
say that the majority of the material
that's in the book is either from the
justices themselves in oral interviews
or it's material that they wrote what we
found very quickly and talking with them
was that there on the court for so many
years I mean several of them have been
on in excess of 20 years you have
gentlemen in some cases that are getting
rather up there in years and in fact
have relatively little time to devote to
the interview
but when they do begin to reflect they
often can't differentiate between the
bussing case that came up in 1971 from
the bussing case that came up in 73 from
the busing case that came up in 75 they
remember that there was a kind of
evolution of the issues but they can't
recall quite which one it was that a
particular event happened in so early on
the justices said well you know you have
to check with my clerks on that because
the clerk's are the ones that will
remember what happened in a particular
year because they generally only clerk
for a one-year period so we went to a
reservoir of potential interviewees
people who have sources of information
on the court who had really never been
tapped before which was the Supreme
Court Clerk's themselves most chambers
have three or four clerks for a year as
Sage justices three or four clerks for a
year and then we covered a seven-year
period so we had quite a few people that
we could talk to and they tended to
remember with great precision the cases
that they worked on what their justice
said what their justice said other
justices said so even though they didn't
participate in all of the events the
justices go into a conference room every
week to decide cases and they closed the
doors there's nobody else in there that
no clerks there's no secretary there's
no there's no minutes taken other than
their own notes but they go back and
they tell they're just their clerks what
happened those clerks then tend to take
notes they tend to remember it so we
were able to reconstruct with fairly I
think decent precision everything's held
up over time that we wrote in the book
with precision exactly what happened and
it was with the help of both the
justices and the clerk's that we could
do it now age is a real issue especially
now that the majority of the justices
are very much up there in age as you
know a lot of people say the president
might be appointing a record number of
justices his second term in office but
is age one of those things that is we
need in Supreme Court justice in the
sense to provide some historical context
in that they've been a judge for a very
very long time they know the development
of major issues to the course of time
and it gives them some of that
philosopher or historical context that
you need a Supreme Court well I don't
think age per se is an is any
qualification for service in the Supreme
Court
it might seem so at times but
essentially public service and an
exposure to the issues in public service
I think is the is what what over time
has proven to be the best qualifier for
the Supreme Court if somebody comes out
of a small law practice where most of
the issues they dealt with we're
relatively narrow and limited issues the
the focus that they're likely to have is
not going to be the greater good of the
public
if they're concerned with if they've
been in the legislature if they've had
an exposure to issues that the the
appellate levels previously if they
understand how these issues would
traditionally come up then they're more
likely to be able to deal with the
issues again and again tell us something
about Chief Justice burger well the
chief justice is quite quite a character
but I think anyone's standards by his
own or by the standards of his
colleagues he came on the court as a
Nixon appointee someone that the that
Richard Nixon and I think the then
Attorney General the United States John
Mitchell felt was perfectly cast for the
role in fact that was the term that was
used that it would almost come out of
central casting as a Supreme Court Chief
Justice he was also very result-oriented
he was very politically motivated and
his previous court experience had
indicated that he was quite outspoken on
certain issues was willing to get
involved in the political fray so when
they appointed him I think they felt and
to some extent as colleagues say
appropriately so that he was a
politically motivated Supreme Court
justice and that as chief justice he
would try and bring the court along in
the direction that the Nixon
administration wanted him to bring it
this is a UPI photo printed in a
yearbook the Brethren of Earl Warren and
Chief Justice burger what was the
transition between these these to a
drastic change in the court well it was
a dramatic change the as Warren was
stepping down there was a tradition in
the court of the justices getting along
in a relatively elegant way of Supreme
Court deliberations taking place with at
least consistency among the justices
that allowed them to to focus on the
issues they could disagree severely
there could be extraordinary arguments
but there was a sense of that things
were done in the up and up when the new
Chief Justice came in he made some some
changes he hit the ground running as it
were
made some changes in the internal proof
procedures of the court which to some
extent I think offended some of his
colleagues they thought he was trying to
take over a little bit too much power
the previous Chief Justice Earl Warren
had been the first among equals this
Chief Justice felt like he was really
the chief justice like he was the head
of a branch of government and that was a
new feeling for the other justices so it
took a while for them to get used to him
and him to get used to them he said
Warren burger coming in as chief justice
he was sort of willing to get into the
political fracas get involved a little
bit more as time has gone on has the job
of a chief justice or the job of being
on the Supreme Court become more of a
political job and if they are more
involved politically with perhaps the
agenda that the president is setting or
the Attorney General
well this Chief Justice Warren burger
has in fact been outspoken on a number
of issues he has not however had the
kind of political contacts and the kind
of he has not yielded to the invitations
that some people have thought have come
out of the the Nixon White House and now
out of the Reagan White House to be even
more political the court to some extent
I think has restrained him he has had or
developed a respect for the institution
which has exceeded what some of his
critics thought he might have in the
beginning so it hasn't been as political
as some people had thought our guest is
scott armstrong he's co-author of the
book the Brethren which you might have
heard this came out the Brethren came
out exactly when Brennan came out in
December 1979 we're discussing the
December 1979 book this week because
each evening here on c-span for about
three hours each evening we're taking a
very close look at the judiciary how it
works and talking to some of the people
who are critical and involved as well in
the judicial process talking a little
bit about politics and the Supreme Court
I want to read a a quote from your book
it's actually page page 10 of the
Brethren it talks a little bit about the
politics of of a president picking a
Supreme Court justice and what they're
looking for I read this and this is
talking about Earl Warren the former
Justice it says he had never imagined
that Dwight Eisenhower would pick him in
1953 Ike said he had chosen Warren for
his quote middle-of-the-road philosophy
end of quote later Eisenhower remarked
that the appointment was quote the
biggest damn fool mistake I ever made
presidents now do they take a good deal
more time to try to make sure they don't
make the biggest damn fool mistake of
their presidential careers well there's
there's certainly no president who is
who has ignored those words by
Eisenhower everyone's aware that the
importance of appointing a Supreme Court
justice and yet it does seem that the
decisions are made in relative haste
there's usually a kind of running a list
of candidates for the court that's
banded about by the legal profession but
whatever finally comes down to it the
decision is usually made in just a few
days a few hours of kind of pressured
consideration of is this the sort of
person that will make decisions the way
we want to have them made and inevitably
the decision is wrong also in your book
quoting in same page throughout the 1968
presidential campaign Nixon had run
against Warren in his court as much as
he had run against his Democratic rival
senator Hubert Humphrey playing on
prejudice and rage particularly in the
south Nixon had promised that his
appointees to the Supreme Court would be
different sounds like the appointments
of Supreme Court are very much a
political operation a political
political role well I think they are I
think we've seen now the current
Attorney General at Mies is beginning to
introduce this in this subject into the
public debate again by being constantly
critical of the court and by suggesting
that the court is doing something
inappropriate in its interpretation of
the Constitution Meese has introduced
the notion that there is an appropriate
interpretation of the Constitution that
he's going to find the people that can
make that appropriate interpretation and
he's going to put them on the Supreme
Court and I think that raises a lot of
eyebrows and among Supreme Court
scholars and the court itself and among
a legal profession because they wonder
what does he mean by that does he
already have somebody in mind that is
going to vote his way and what is that
way is what the Attorney General ed
Meese is doing or saying really anything
new that was a quote from Nixon's
campaign of 68 and it sounded like the
same things been going on a long time is
this really anything new well it's not
anything new to the notion that you want
to have a Supreme Court that's somehow
going to come out with some sort of
different result what's different about
what Meese is saying is is the degree to
which it's totally uninformed and
ignorant we have I think for the first
time in in recent memory an attorney
general who's so wholly unqualified for
the job we I think there been other
candidates for them
most unqualified Attorney General but
Mises exceeded them by such a quantum
that it that I don't think it leaves
much question and what he's done is
essentially he's trying to rewrite
history by completely ignoring it he's
saying well all of the Supreme Court has
to do is interpret what the
constitutional fathers said about the
Constitution they just need to go back
to its original intention its original
meaning it's a nice theory it sounds
like the constitutional fathers got
together and agreed upon a constitution
and said this is exactly what it means
what any scholar for that matter anybody
who studied American history anybody
who's had a civics course knows that the
Constitution was founded with enormous
controversy with enormous disagreements
about what different phrases meant and
with a lot of ambiguity and the
Constitution itself is a product of a
very deliberate attempt by Benjamin
Franklin and others to bring people who
disagreed totally about how the country
should be organized to bring them
together to say look let's agree upon a
document that is somewhat vague somewhat
ambiguous but let's agree upon it such
that we can see if it works over time
but let's just keep reinterpreting it
let's work toward something so what we
have is two hundred years of a very
successful gambit at government I mean
no one knew if the United States would
make it or not two hundred years ago but
the Supreme Court has been a vital
institution in the way the government
functions it has constantly been
reinterpreting the Constitution and the
statutes in the light of current events
and that's the way it was designed to be
and along comes someone and says well we
just have to go back to the original
meaning it clearly shows he knows
nothing about the history of the
Constitution full lines are open for
viewers in all areas the country
something a little different this
morning in the sense that we're
concentrating on the Supreme Court not
necessarily what might be on the front
page or the inside of your newspaper
today for the Supreme Court in general
question or comments and things you
might have heard the president or
attorney general ed Meese say something
you'd like to add to our conversation or
a question you'd like to ask this is the
opportunity for that if you live in the
eastern and central time zones it's two
oh two six two eight two five two five
and those of you in Pacific and mountain
time zones 202 seven eight three two
seven two seven Houston Texas go ahead
please the office of former Senator John
tower I could just hint that's the
subject
piñon of either the Supreme Court nor as
the district courts benign have in my
hands within two weeks and as a
physicist I believe we sisters have
better tools of logic than the legal
profession does I think the legal
profession operates in its own
self-interest as I understand that the
inscription on above the Supreme Court
building on the front is equal justice
under the law and the people behind in
the building right the law there's one
specific opinion or one specific
statement made by Chief Justice burger
that identifies the doctrine of judicial
anarchy it's about the top of page 61
and the brother and if I'm not mistaken
where he specified to Associate Justice
Harlan we are the Supreme Court we can
do what we want I never got around to
asking John tower for a full compilation
of the judicial doctrines I wish I would
have when we had somebody in office that
appreciated a bit of intellect but I
submit that this doctrine of judicial
arity has been substantially extended to
state and federal courts for via the
stump versus Sparkman opinion a 15 year
old girl was ordered sterilized without
hearing without her knowledge catalog
didn't the judge the authority they want
the Supreme Court and white wrote the
most sophist opinion ever the original
Supreme Court of judicial child sexual
abuse
I'd like your comments Houston Texas
thanks for the call any comments Scott
Armstrong well I'm not I'm not quite
sure how to frame the comments I think
the the most important thing is to
distinguish between the courts
obligation to interpret the law and to
understand the law as a moving
institution through time when a statutes
written when a when the Constitution
itself was was was formed agreed upon no
one quite knew where it's going to lead
and there's always a matter of
interpretation in the context of
individual facts in the context of
individual circumstances this is what
the business of the judiciary is to make
that interpretation that interpretation
requires some
flexibility requires some creativity it
requires an understanding of the
fundamental principles of government it
requires an appreciation for the forces
in society that need to be reconciled
and in that extent the Supreme Court is
going to mold and shape and change the
law there's no question about it it
should that's its job on the other hand
the caller's right
no one has appointed the members of the
Supreme Court in order to write laws
they are not meant there to sweep aside
what Congress does they're not meant
there to to put aside the intent of the
state legislatures they're there to
reconcile it in view of the Constitution
and so their role is limited but it's
limited within that framework that they
are in fact meant to interpret it so I
think we have to there's a balance on
each side if they're just sweeping
things away if they're if they're
essentially voting only their conscience
establishing law from from nothing then
that's inappropriate but if they're
interpreting things that might have
what's gone before that is exactly what
they're supposed to be doing phone lines
are open for viewers in all areas the
country if you have a question or a
comment we'd certainly like to hear from
you those numbers are there at the
bottom of your screen Largo Florida go
ahead please I have a question about
seminars for federal judges on busing
cases I'd like to state my understanding
of what happened there several years ago
one of the federal judges mentioned the
fact that he had attended a seminar on
busing while he was considering a busing
case and before it meant to appeal he
said that that seminar had been
conducted in Washington and I believe
the multi district litigation office I
called that office and was told all no
we didn't hold that seminar was held in
the federal courts building I called the
federal courts building and they said we
have nothing in writing but that seminar
was held for a number of federal judges
they said if you want any more
information you'll have to call mrs.
Henson at New York University because
one of their professors conducted the
seminar and I wonder if you would
consider it appropriate for federal
judges secretly to be lectured by
professor's on issues that are pending
before them and the thing that concerns
me a great deal is that all of the
information given the judges by New York
University professor to the effect that
there would be no white flight as a
result of ordered busing was absolutely
wrong and had a terrible effect on the
economic strength of central cities
Largo Florida thanks for the call the
caller raises an excellent question
because underlying the question is the
question is the notion that does the
court get adequate information to do its
job from the process of cases coming up
on a cert petition of reviewing that
petition of having the issues briefed by
both sides of reading the briefs of
taking amicus briefs that are brought in
by third parties who want to contribute
some ideas to the thing hashing through
that and then coming out with a decision
and the answer frankly is no we're
talking about ultimate societal
questions we're talking about ultimate
decisions we're talking about a
frustrated court that has seen the
results of the decision-making fail
again and again and they're looking for
new approaches they're looking for new
things not just at the Supreme Court
level I might add but at all levels so
what you have is I think a need for some
new ideas for new expertise for ranging
from everything from bussing I think
there's only one example to technology
the caller's question though is a secret
session that involves federal court
judges and gives them information and an
interpretation and some background
sociology if you will about what bussing
will mean if they go ahead and order it
is that appropriate and the answer there
is clearly no anything in the federal
judiciary that secret other than the
actual decision-making itself is
inappropriate the the the basis of the
decision the facts that are considered
must be a matter of public record that's
our whole judicial decision-making is
based on that notion if they read the
newspaper that's considered okay they
all read the newspaper and that's
available to anyone who reads it but if
they essentially have a secret newspaper
a secret briefing a secret lecture then
that's something that's not available
for each
to criticize to to look at to examine to
rebut to add information to so that's
clearly inappropriate Athens Ohio go
ahead please I'd like to ask a question
concerning the comments made about mr.
Meese and his view that the
interpretation of the Constitution
should be toward the literal side and
obviously the guests view is that it
should allow for somewhat more
flexibility and maybe subjectivity in
terms of different circumstances the
question is when you have two opposing
views of how things should be done and
we obviously have throughout our history
when appointees are being made them is
to call one side ignorant any does that
make the person doing the calling any
better than the person he's talking
about wouldn't it be better to recognize
that there are legitimate and valid
views as to how the interpretations
should be made well I think there
absolutely are two sides of the issue
and they're legitimate and valued valid
views the Attorney General United States
is not one of the people that holds
either of those views or any of those
views his interpretation is basically an
interpretation which is totally
unsupported by American history when you
say a literal interpretation there is
some support for the notion that there
should be what could be called a literal
interpretation in the sense of a narrow
or more constrained interpretation what
Meese is gone for is is something far
beyond that what he said is we have to
go back to the original intent
the precise intent as if there was a
single intent of the founding fathers he
said in us in a sense that the that the
Constitution needs to be interpreted as
if it were totally colorblind and issues
such as affirmative action now he does
not want affirmative action programs
that tend to favor what he minority
groups who are attempting to recoup past
losses and says that the Constitution is
was colorblind that the the Bill of
Rights is colorblind this is just not
the case the Constitution was not
colorblind the Constitution was was
written by men who held slaves it was
written to incorporate slavery it was
meant to be part of a slaveholding
Society subsequently that was seen to be
incorrect in
appropriate and the the 14th amendment
other amendments were added strictly for
the purpose of bringing into play some
countervailing forces to correct the
original influence of the Constitution
it was not colorblind at all it was
meant to take into account the context
of things were going on at the time so
while there's a there there's a place
for a point of view that certainly
differs from mine that there's a range
of points of view on what this what the
different statutes different amendments
of the Constitution the Constitution
itself means one of the things that is
not within the range of I think
acceptable debate is the notion that
there is a single view there has to be a
multiplicity of views it's it's the
Attorney General in all it's the view
not me that there's a single point of
view so I would say that anyone who
holds the point of view that there's a
single view is in fact ignorant and that
that's an appropriate thing to call him
and that's what fits the Attorney
General Shiprock New Mexico your next go
ahead please how are you today
he wrote that one man could decide that
the so many states has ratified
something and you could give all the
evidence you could find and it would
still not be you know the Supreme Court
would not reexamine it regardless how
much evidence you found to the contrary
that the those states had ratified it so
I wrote the Supreme Court about that and
I got back a letter and he says I cannot
discuss this thing and I hope you will
understand
I'd like your remarks on that which
Supreme Court justice did you write
caller I wrote two Supreme Court Brian
White who was the all-american football
player and he had a 98% grade average in
college
can I ask you very quickly what was the
issue when you wrote him about it was
about one man deciding that everybody in
the Supreme that 38 states had ratified
something okay Shiprock thanks for the
call if I understand the caller's
question correctly the the it's why
can't a Supreme Court justice and
or a simple letter asking for asking for
information on a particular issue and I
think the the the answer is fairly
straightforward the court has made the
decision from its from its beginning
that it will speak officially only
through its in its final opinions that
are issues as a result that allows these
nine men and women to to come together
and reconcile their points of view they
can dissent they can concur they can do
a variety of things that that that shape
their their opinions but they can do it
in a way that's relatively precise that
has the kind of language that they want
to include in there by doing it in a
written form by allowing each other the
comment on it if they each started
writing letters on each issue then
decisions would never be final then
because somebody constant
reinterpretation every letter that a
Supreme Court Justice wrote would amend
essentially previous things that he'd
written and the law would be chaos in
order to have some stability in the law
there has to be some sense of finality
our guest is scott armstrong this
morning he's co-author of this book the
brethren you may have seen it on in
bookstores or newsstands around the
country we're discussing the Supreme
Court and specifically the judiciary and
this we hear on c-span specifically
every evening this week we're taking
about three hours three and a half four
hours and looking specifically just how
some of these justices do their job and
talking about the judicial system and
listening to some critics and some of
those that actually participate in the
system part of our week-long worth of
programming as an interview with judges
Kenneth Starr and Abner Mikva we talked
to them several weeks back about the
problem of litigation and too much
litigation and overwhelming judges we
asked them both of that question and
this is what they had to say in response
I'm not so sure that I want to figure
out spend too much time either to watch
the Congress or the state legislatures
close up the courthouse doors the other
side of saying we're a litigious society
is to say that we really are a society
that believes in the rule of law that
people really think they can get justice
from a court that they can resolve a
dispute amicably
I'm not amicably in the sense of they're
gonna agree on it but that they're going
to have a peaceful resolution of their
dispute without seeing who had fits the
army on their side and who gets the
navier-- who can shoot the straightest
or draw the fastest and the fact that
matter is that much of the explosion in
litigation has been over personal rights
employment discrimination landlord
Kennet disputes disputes in the
workplace the protection legislation
that Congress has passed whether it's
over the environment or over health or
whatever that end up in court in terms
of their enforcement I think that's been
healthy I think that has has as extended
and broadened our democracy because we
that there was a time back in our
history early in our country and
throughout much of the of England's
history when the courts really were the
the the preserve of the rich you didn't
bring a lawsuit to court unless you had
a lot of money and we sad jester law
wasn't there for the poor people the
there was no landlord-tenant law in the
early days it was only landlord law the
credit laws cut it her laws all tilted
in favor of the creditor including the
right to put the debtor in prison if
they didn't pay all of that has changed
as we have democratized our society and
that's why we're a little society
because more people with little disputes
are bringing those disputes to court
that interview with judge Abner Mikva
and also judge Kenneth Starr will err in
its entirety that's coming friday
evening at 8 p.m. Eastern Time what do
you think of what judgment Abner Mikva
calls an explosion of litigation is it
currently expanding mushrooming out of
control in our country well I think that
there is a deep-seated concern about now
types of issues that the federal
judiciary faces but the sheer number of
things that end up in court now the
expense of going to court the delays
that are involved in going to court and
these all require some some creative
management and some solution but at the
same time and I think this is exactly a
mcfist point judge maker was quite right
in identifying this is being what's
great about the American rule of law
there are many societies there the
totalitarian societies but there also
other so-called democratic societies
societies that that America has as
allies that don't have this this rule of
law we have I mean Asian countries that
are our allies that are supposedly
running democratic principles where if
there's going to be an unemployment
problem or there's going to be a problem
of in the workplace they immediately
start being concerned about whether
nothing to be riots in front of the in
front of their Executive Mansion in this
country when there's a problem with a
crisis of civil rights or crisis of
unemployment or whatnot that we have
demonstrations we certainly have some a
certain amount of unrest but we don't
have riots in front of the White House
not only we have other ways to go about
it and the legal system can absorb and
take this kind of societal pressure and
resolve it and that has I think made for
made America a great society how many
cases is on the averages as a Supreme
Court here each year well the the number
of cases they actually hear is quite
small it's in excess of a hundred but
it's the number of cases that are really
argued out and really become matters of
debate internally probably is somewhat
less than 100 the that is to say that
there are some open-and-shut cases that
they bring up and they dispense with
quite quickly but there by that token
that's a that small number it has to be
compared with a huge number of cases
that are offered to them to take that
are the petitions that are that are
brought to them that in order to try and
get them to deal with the issue there
we're talking about an explosion where a
dozen years ago was a thousand petitions
it's now 4,000 5,000 6,000 and you end
up with an extraordinary amount of
discretion that they have as to which
issues they'll take that's good in the
sense that they can sometimes pick
exactly the right case but it also means
that they have to avoid resolving an
awful lot of things that happen
blow Sandy Springs George you go ahead
please yes I want to go back to I
believe it's mr. Anderson his quotation
of Benjamin Franklin but first let me
say I'm well I'll call myself legal
activist and that I challenge
constitutional questions in the state in
federal court acting procedure that is
as my own attorney so I feel that I'm
quite a student of the Constitution you
know hobby
let me first quote Sam Erwin who says
I'm not among the legal activists who
would interpret the Constitution to say
what it would have said if they not the
founding fathers had written it and what
I'd like to ask your guest is and I've
read the miracle of Philip at
Philadelphia for example that quotation
that he made of Benjamin Franklin about
the contents of a constitution I
challenged they that he has inserted in
there that it is subject to future
interpretation I forget exactly how you
put it but I want to ask him if indeed
he quoted Ben Franklin exactly
Georgia thanks for the call well I
wasn't quoting a Benjamin Franklin I was
paraphrasing and I believe accurately
the role that Franklin played and
bringing the members of the
Constitutional Convention together I
think it looking back in American
history there's there's no question that
one now can can say that a particular
interpretation of the Constitution may
not be anything close to what the
founding fathers said what I'm trying to
point to is the notion that the founding
fathers did not agree upon a single
interpretation the founding fathers
themselves had many interpretations of
what the Constitution they were signing
meant and there was a lot of dissension
about whether or not they should sign it
there was a period immediately prior to
the sign of the Constitution when it
wasn't so clear that we were going to
get a constitution out of it and at the
point when they signed it there were
many disagreements about what in fact
they were signing what it meant how it
would work and and and what the balances
of power would be so what I'm suggesting
is that anybody who signed it not
realizing that it was going to be
subject to extraordinary interpretation
and I'm going into
datian was was wholly unaware of what
they were doing and I have a much
greater faith in our founding fathers
than than that I believe that they were
quite winning when they realized that
looked for the greater good of the
country we're gonna try and come
together it's the best constitution we
can come up with we don't quite know how
it's gonna work we're gonna let things
settle out here but we're gonna move
forward with it that's exactly what
happened and that's exactly what we have
today are born Massachusetts good
morning and go ahead please come on last
year rose bred the California Supreme
Court threw out an inertia petition that
was when since 1980 we watched the guys
on the House floor push for a line-item
veto and a constitutional amendment to
balance the budget and she threw out the
entire initiative petition on the
grounds that the people cannot get a
petition and forced the legislature the
state legislature to call a
constitutional convention for a balanced
budget the legislature has to do it
itself and nobody challenged Rose bird
on that decision and I'm sure other
states who have agreed to call for a
constitutional convention to balance the
budget and line-item veto possibly if
the Supreme Court of that state looked
on into it would arrive at the same
decision that the people do not have
that right to force the state
legislature to call a constitutional
convention only the state legislatures
had to take a vote and do it so when I
watch the gramm-rudman get attached in
that Senate extension of the debt limit
it was a line-item no committee hearings
no debate nothing no checking whether it
was constitutional it was hung on that
debt limit if it was in the house it
could never have happened
it had have been started they wouldn't
have allowed it because it would be a
lie
an appropriation a money Bill now why
didn't like Rose bird of California
someone in that house of Senate asked a
ruling from the Supreme Court is this
gramm-rudman constitutional as written
that would have saved a whole lot of
baloney that all the nation is listening
to I take a call you think that's
unconstitutional then oh yes because
they were they were giving the power to
CBO and OMB they're nothing but hired
hands for the house and the president
and this when does the hired hand make
the decision it doesn't allow a congress
to override a veto of a president
Massachusetts thanks for the call we
appreciate it
Scott Armstrong any comment on that at
all well the I have no comment on the
merits of the the case I'm not
sufficiently familiar with it to come in
there I think the caller's question is
why does the court not issue advisory
opinions and save us all a lot of time I
think the court could could essentially
stop hearing cases that come up in
society and just sit there and review
what the legislature had done every year
and say this law is unconstitutional
this law is constitutional this law is
this problem that law is that problem
and that's essentially not the not the
courts role it never has been and the
courts role for the beginning has been
to take cases of law that come up to it
that are specific in their nature that
have that have actual litigants an
actual problem that's it's already posed
it's out there and I think the reason
for it is the reason that's important to
understand if first of all if the court
started getting involved in passing
judgment on what the legislature did it
would exceed its power you wouldn't have
the kind of balance of powers that that
I believe the founding fathers had at
least some sense of when they passed the
Constitution they wanted the the the the
the Supreme Court to be able to balance
the legislature but they didn't want to
have it jump into the middle of it and
being interpreting what it should be
doing but the most important part of
this is that when Congress passes a law
it often itself does not know what the
precise effect will be it's it has a
hunch it hopes that this will resolve
this or that or that
going to work toward a particular
solution but it takes the the executive
branch has to implement it there other
forces in society when particularly when
they're dealing with broad societal
issues like busing or abortion or the
death penalty or the criminal
protections or civil rights where they
don't quite know how it's going to play
out when a law is is passed in whether
it's the federal or state legislature
and it takes a while for those issues to
begin to get reconciled and for them to
come through the courts and the the
lower courts often have some creative
solutions they see things at a local
level they understand what the local
forces are and it takes a while for
these issues to take shape and the
Supreme Court likes to watch that
process happen so that the issues are
better drawn better formed and issues
that are trivial that will that will
drop away an hour can drop away and only
the important ones come up to them both
the House and the Senate have a
committee staff known as Legislative
Council which is a group of lawyers
which simply look and help senators and
congressmen write lawyers there is a
good deal of legal advice offered isn't
there throughout the writing of
legislation yes I mean the there's
there's no shortage of constitutional
scholars in in the country and certainly
not in Washington and they certainly
able to to give Congress appropriate
advice about what what previous
precedents what the Constitution itself
means in the context particularly
legislation Congress is also quite free
to ignore that in in quite free to go
off in its own direction and the caller
may have identified one of those areas I
simply don't know Fayetteville Arkansas
good morning to you and go ahead please
yes the first thing I'd like to say is
that I want to compliment mr. Armstrong
on the book the brethren which I thought
it was just a fantastic book but what I
would like to talk about is the fact
that Jimmy Carter who was the only
Democratic president in the 70s or maybe
the 80s was what the FIR only full-time
president in American history to appoint
no one to the Supreme Court and I would
like to know what his impact on the
judiciary was and if you have any sense
of who he would have appointed had he
had the opportunity it's an excellent
question I
I'm not privy to any inside information
about who he would have appointed to the
court he did have an opportunity to make
a to make a mark on the judiciary
because there was an expansion of the
judiciary during that period and there
were a number of vacancies that that the
Carter ministration filled and there was
a there was a very substantial shift
toward women and minorities in in the
pattern of appointments a shift by the
way I should point out has been
continued to some degree by the Reagan
administration I mean it was it started
with Carter but didn't necessarily in
there Reagan has himself appointed a
greater number of women and minorities
than previous presidents the I think it
was very disappointing to Carter that he
didn't get an opportunity to make some
some appointments I think he originally
intended to do it in a second term
and the fact that he didn't have that
option as something the American
electorate had a lot to do with so the
the the present situation we have now
with so many of the justices over 70
although they seem to be in better
health now than they were a year ago as
a group but it does look like we're very
likely to have during this presidential
term a number of vacancies and a number
of appointments and it certainly would
be a different group of people that
Ronald Reagan will be a point of the
Supreme Court than the ones that Jimmy
Carter would your book the Brethren
deals with a the court burger court from
68 to 76 I have seen reports in
newspapers and books that make reference
to President Nixon making a comment that
his most lasting and perhaps greatest
contribution is in his years as
president or the people who pointed to
the Supreme Court and the way he perhaps
changed the Supreme Court did you in
doing your research hear anything of
that nature and did President Nixon have
a substantial impact on this court well
I think we the the goal that that
Richard Nixon set with the Supreme Court
in
his his goal was a court that's
substantially different from the way
this one has turned out it has not been
it has not been the Nixon court that he
might have hoped because it did not go
down the path of sweeping away the
precedents of the Warren Court did not
did not shift gears shift directions
change totally its emphasis and the
nature of judicial decision-making what
it did do however was it certainly
slowed the pace at which the Warren
Court the the previous Supreme Court had
had gone in the in the expansion of
civil rights and protections civil
liberties protections for Americans
under the law so to the extent that the
that essentially he stopped something
that he thought was wrong that he
thought was an excessive use of judicial
activism by a group of relatively the
liberal justices Nixon was successful to
the extent that he was able to sweep
back those changes in some wholesale way
or was able to to to go in a different
direction and tighten things up it
certainly was not the Nixon court that
he intended it to be but there are still
all those appointees there and with with
the replacement of two or three justices
if justices Marshall and justices
Brennan the two most liberal justices on
the court were to leave they're both in
their in their mid 70s if they were to
leave and be replaced by conservative
Reagan appointees we could see the Nixon
majority as it were become influential
in a number of areas that it hasn't
previously Scott Armstrong co-author of
this book the Brethren discussing the
Supreme Court judicial system San Diego
California good morning go ahead please
how are you today
[Applause]
a little bit ago I'm not sure rather
than touched on that but it's from
success has really disturbed me and a
woman earthly has been in the black
particularly I'm speaking in reference
to the way the gentlemen put together he
was saying about the court interpreting
interpreting rather and also about
mentioned abortion I have taken the time
to read the wording rose versus raised
and a code
the worry that the Supreme Court puts
down
for slate and for the existence of slave
and for the legality of sleep and
reading the to the wording exact where
their similarity is but frightens me
about it is that the court said that
blacks were not legally in Roe versus
Wade they're saying that the fetus are
not legally that words and play on words
and I would like the gentleman San Diego
thanks for the call Scott Armstrong it's
important to recognize that what the
Court did in roe v wade in the abortion
decisions it's not something that they
took lightly nor was it something that
they necessarily agreed upon this was a
decision in which there were at least
nine different points of view present
they struggled over two terms they put
the case off for one term and took it up
essentially in in the next term so it
really went over a two-year period which
is very unusual in order to try and come
up with some consensus and what
ultimately emerged was an opinion that I
don't think anybody was was
extraordinarily happy with but they all
felt that they had that was something
that was that was a viable opinion in
the sense of trying to resolve the
societal questions that were present and
it's not so much their decision that a
fetus is not a human being that needs to
be focused on here that they certainly
did decide that that certainly is a is
something that's implicit in the
decision it's explicit to some degree in
in in some portions of the logic and
the text of the decision but what they
were talking about here was the fact
that there are other more palpable
societal rights society rights of
individuals that need to be respected
and examined and they particularly
identified the rights of course the
those women who are carrying a fetus as
to what they want to do with their body
and with that fetus but what I think
surprised people was that the decision
came down very heavily in favor of what
doctors are likely to advise a woman
who's carrying a fetus to do and that
the doctors have a role in this process
and that the doctors as a profession
that's been sanctioned by government
that has been is regulated by government
is regulated by state legislatures that
doctors have an obligation to give
advice they have an obligation to the to
their patients to the medical profession
and and to government and they have to
be free to exercise that to the best
medical knowledge that they can they can
bring and what this decision largely
revolves upon is the notion that at that
particular point in time
a fetus of a certain age was not a
viable entity if you took it out of the
womb into the into the environment it
was not likely to survive therefore it
was not according to what they
considered to be the legal definition of
human being and therefore its rights
were not something that they were going
to be considering at that time they're
considering the rights of women the
rights of doctors so you have a very
unusual decision that essentially says
that women have the right to along with
their doctor to decide whether or not
they want to have an abortion so it's
really doctors rights and women's rights
and it certainly explicitly leaves aside
fetal rights how it compares with the
slavery decisions I think is again goes
back to the notion that they're trying
to interpret based on some sort of
consistent principles but it's very
difficult this is not an issue in which
any interpretation would have easily
gone back and been consonant with what
the founders had had projected when they
were at the Constitution you assisted in
the research and writing of Woodward and
Bernstein's book the final days
co-author of this book the Brethren
you're now on leave from the Washington
Post and you're working on a book about
national security policy supposed to
come out in 86 how far are you along in
that book and exactly what would it be
about well
of course as always with an author never
quite as far along as I'd like to be or
it should be at this point but I'm
largely done with my research and in
nearly done with the writing I'm
essentially trying to go back and strip
down the assumptions we have about how
the national security decision-making
process works begin to look at the
National Security Council the cabinet
officials that participate in that their
assistance in some sense go back as we
did in the brethren talk to those people
about what they really do for a living
as opposed to what we read about in the
newspapers find out what really went
into decisions as opposed to what they
said went into the decisions when they
leaked stories initially and with a
little bit more documentation a little
bit more opportunity to reflect outside
of the limelight without the pressures
of trying to persuade Congress of this
particular defense budget or trying to
negotiate that particular treaty be able
to reconstruct events in a way that I
hope will describe to the public how our
national security policy develops how
foreign policy develops why it is that
we're locked in the kind of armed
struggle that we we have been with the
Soviet Union and how that affects our
relationships worldwide what quickly
some of the national security issues
that you're dealing with explaining in
this then well largely concentrating on
on two tracks one is Central America and
the other one is the Middle East to try
and explain what goes on there in great
detail and then beginning to show how
while we have a lot of expertise some
very qualified government officials to
deal with those issues
when they begin to to look at the same
two sequences in context of us-soviet
relations everything changes and that
our concern with the Soviet Union is so
overarching that it essentially shapes
policy well into the future so to a
large extent what I'm trying to explain
is why things happen today that are not
really caused by events yesterday many
of the things in the National Security
sphere are caused because we want to be
able to prevail 15 years from now in
World War 3 World War three is a war
that we don't want to lose so therefore
are willing to do things today in order
to prevail 15 years from now that causes
things today and it's very hard to
explain the Cal charge a good morning go
ahead please yes my thesis is or my
point is I think it's
point of part of the main message of
your book is that the culture and the
psychological the psychic outlook of the
individual judge determines the law
rather than some artificial bill affair
as far as interpret interpreting the
Constitution
I studied the Constitution leaving off
in the late 1960s a Mason and beany book
and it looks to me like that the it's
very the Supreme Court is very important
and we never can discount that but
overall these fellows are part of our
society and little Clause can be
interpreted in any number of ways and
it's a product of the times more than it
is a law per se because law per se is
only it's a positive manufactured part
of man and that article in Time magazine
about the great debate that's going on
at Harvard Law School right now it was
fascinating to me because it confirmed
that there is a great split in in just
just what the law is and I'd like to
have your comment on that and I know I
haven't been very clear but I'd like you
to clear it up for me well there's an
old adage that that lawyers or law
school students seem to get when they're
in law school all about if you want to
if you want to succeed in a case in law
you have to be able to do one of three
things know one of three things better
than your opponent you either have to
know the facts better if know the law
better or you have to know the judge
better and I think what's been implicit
in in that interpretation of the law and
essentially the American judicial system
is that judges do have an enormous
amount of influence and flexibility the
the appellate courts of course are
supposedly dealing only in a neutral
environment with with the facts and with
the laws it's given to them in a record
that they're not really involved in
developing it comes up to them on paper
they're asking questions reposing posing
questions so that they can perfect the
information and make their
interpretation but obviously the human
element interpretation is absolutely
extraordinary by the same token though I
think it's a mistake to to say that
these are these are judges who are
simply voting their predilections who
are simply saying to themselves well
let's see I I'm a little tired of what's
going on in American society right now
in this particular sphere so I think
I'll start voting a different way in the
in my decisions that isn't what's
happening what's happening our attempts
by laymen who've been schooled in law
and not necessarily in history to really
interpret the the Constitution interpret
the laws as historians as philosophers
as legal scholars but to interpret them
in the sense of what was intended what
it is that's that that our founding
fathers and subsequent legislatures
legislators have intended for the
country what are the ideals that they've
that they're striving for how do we best
implement them in the contemporary
situation and so I think there really is
a good faith effort to to move toward
interpretation but yes it's horribly
dependent on who the individuals are
what their backgrounds has been and
where they are we have a very the
Supreme Court is largely male and it's
largely white it's largely middle-class
and it's obviously all lawyers so it
comes from a very narrow segment of
society and they do their best to
broaden their experience to try and deal
with other factors but it's their
backgrounds that are relevant to the
decisions that they make San Diego
California you've got about a minute yes
I'm kind of not graduating on this book
I read the book and I thought it was an
indictment on the conservatives and I
think his approach to it was a little
devious in the sense that he tried to
make Berger come off as a buffoon and I
think that to me I was that well I don't
think we had to try very hard to make
Warren Berger come off as a buffoon the
the Chief Justice whose public persona
is much different than his private
persona inside the court it was
considered to be a buffoon by some of
his colleagues and that came
loud and clear to us and we wrote that
to some extent I will I will confess
that we looked we certainly gave a harsh
scrutiny to the the Conservatives that
were there we went in expecting much
more result oriented series of
operations inside the court we didn't
find it well we found were men who quite
sincerely tried to do what they were
doing and that includes the Chief
Justice he has less of the respect of
his colleagues because I think he's
earned less of their respect but in fact
the Conservatives as a whole came off I
think in the book quite well and we're
quite pleased with the book by the way
our guest for the last hour has been
Scott Armstrong co-author of the book
the brother and currently executive
director with the National Security
Archive Scott thank you very much for
getting up early and joining us this
hour you go those of you who have been
watching and